et il ya quelqu'un voilà je vous le dis
mathieu qui est venu vous voir et qui
énervé contre vous il y a quelques
semaines mathieu vous aviez dit ça sur
un animateur
regardez franchement je regardais plus
comme c'était goudé tous étaient
ringards tout était ringard j'adore alex
goude bas on peut l'aimer mais c'était
ringard et pour autant cela ne regarde
pas ce que le jury meilleur le rythme
est meilleure et franchement bravo alors
l'échelle donc alex goude et là ce soir
et il a quelque chose à vous dire
matthieu delormeau aller
[Applaudissements]
la ilaha illa il a trois retournement
alex comme moi ce que je te donne tu
pètes est vrai qu'elle est venue raconte
une loi mais voilà alors avec sonia la
musque a dit matthieu delormeau de toi
c'est pas la première fois
c'est ce que tu t'es dit et xavier
apparemment ça t'a touché exactement
j'en ai marre de me faire démonter par
mathieu ah bon
[Rires]
et par gilles verdez aussi mais enfin
bon là il est dopé depuis qu'il fait de
l'animation ça me fait plus rien ça m'a
passé au dessus très bien alors non mais
est ce que ça vous a touché oui ça m'a
touché bon déjà c'est un peu compliqué
parce que j'ai fait ces missions pendant
huit ans certes mais bon c'est ya trois
ans a donc le temps a passé et puis
voilà ce qui m'aide skimmers et les
jugements péremptoires parce qu'on peut
dire je n'aime pas je trouve qu'il est
ringard mais dire c'est ringard
parce que tu le prends plein la tête
après il ya deux ou trois twitter qui
commence à s'énerver sa part en furie
pour un truc donc je dis juste bat yeux
voilà donne ton avis mais avec ton rejet
mots je trouve ou ou pour moi il est
ringard voilà je le prendrais mieux je
le prendrais mieux quel avis péremptoire
en disant souhaiter qui fait un truc
c'est ringard même good tu vois c'est un
peu méchant parce que moi je t'appelle
mathieu je t'aime beaucoup changé sur
mes déjà en acceptant que mathieu n'est
pas ringard manex des nations si ça ça
te blesses jeu l'entendre mais déjà il
faut pas faire ce métier si tu sais très
bien qu'on va on va au plus vite c'est
l'émission c'est en direct
alors oui ça clashe un peu moi j'en
prends plein la tête au sciage et ça
nous a tous fait ça si ça ça te blesse
dans ces cas là faut pas faire un métier
tu peux pas voir le meilleur de ce
métier à l'argent les strass les
paillettes rentrer dans des relais
motard est décédé que c'est un peu
compliqué sur twitter à une critique
tu le prends mal donc c'est vrai après
c'est vrai aussi que je dis toujours ce
que je pense et que c'est vrai repas pas
de côté humain humainement que très
sympathique surtout que ton style
d'animation même un petit peu à l'époque
et tout ça un peu à l'ancienne avec des
jeux de mots et tout ça
oui moi je ne suis pas sensible je fais
c'est pas du coup pouvoir vérifier parce
que du coup tu m'as mis le doute tuez
pas facile raconte pour vérifier que ça
fait là bas du cou et j'ai demandé à
votre équipe cube de chercher des images
d'un crois que talent l'époque où je le
faisais il ya longtemps maintenant ça
marche très bien aujourd'hui très
content pour eux trouvé avec ce terrain
garé comme toi tu es juges de paix un
peu c'est un peu le dieu de la télé j'ai
l'envié de jouer à noël tu enlèves non
non non je ne sais pas ce qui a donc
revoir à mon avis que je vais tenir
je vais déjeuner moi je t'ai déjà dit
que je trouvais pas un gars que je
t'aime beaucoup regardent on regarderait
face à nos 4 jurés
chaque candidat doit absolument se dire
prési
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont pas faire ça fait
deux mois que je m'entraîne on peut pas
devenir aussi bon que les candidats en
deux jours un fossé non viens je crois
que nous aussi on pour empocher 100
mille euros comme le grand gagnant
non alex incroyable qu'est ce que si je
joue bien je sais j'ai mis beaucoup de
temps apprend que tu sais qui va piano
va sano
ouais enfin tu as quand même pas le
talent du futur grand gagnant de cette
année
toi moi je pourrais très bien qu'à des
5000 euros et peut-être même envolé à
montréal c'est gilbert n'a pas d'accord
dit la vérité
franchement c'est trop nul on sait
travailler c'est rigolo mais oui ça fait
rigoler moi j'adorais quand j'étais
petit est la part à côté du père noël
merci d'appeler un anime aussi et puis
un truc qui m'agace aussi de la part de
personnalités dont comme toi c'est
clairement donné des textos aller sur
twitter pour essayer de solliciter les
gens et créé des petits bugs pour
exister
ça m'agace pourrait traiter m sur tout
un truc pareil moi par exemple je crois
que j'ai un jugement très péremptoire
comme tu le dis qu'un jour tu as dit 2
tp mp2 cyril hanouna de moi tu as dit un
jour matthieu delormeau fait beaucoup de
mal à la cause homosexuelle avec tpm p
je rêvais d'y envoyer un texto
j'ai pas été nette sur twitter et dit
n'importe quoi regretter jugement il est
dit j'ai les miens oui mais si on veut
se faire aller on envoie un texto
mais elle est sollicitée les gens pour
remuer un peu tout ça et faire du buzz
pour exemple mais je n'ai fait passer
pendant c'est plus difficile pour toi
c'est très bien mais c'est pas difficile
tout va très bien regardent peut-être
hagards mais je suis hyper moderne j'ai
un cloud en ce moment sur france 4 sur
dans drôlement bet inse comme a même qui
en train de piquer les électeurs à
quotidien pour ferrara mais voilà serre
et bien voilà donc tout va très bien
donc je n'y avais arrêté un mais du coup
dans la soirée toujours au dos dans ce
qui est terrible c'est que grâce à
mathieu de mathieu moi je les aime
beaucoup il est pendant des années il me
touchait beaucoup à
et moi jamais je te trouve ringard même
quand tu mets des tenues assez
approximative je crois qu'ils ont trouvé
des images quoi ah oui alors la
désolation radieux mais sa défaite voir
quoi mais au les étés indiens
[Applaudissements]
jamais animé des messieurs on regarde il
a toujours et si elle allait plus loin
que la moyenne avec des émissions
parfois révolutionnaires comme ça quoi
vous allez voir c'est c'est vraiment bon
port public reçoit à vous qui êtes chez
vous soyez les bienvenus
l'urée verticale ou ce qu'on saura el
ali m ça va bien contre stressé tout
comme l imagine forcément c'est
l'événement ce soir sur nrj 12 c'est la
grande première de ouf qu'elle cherchera
à la hauteur en question c'est bon
dernière chose pour alex et pour les
autres d'ailleurs que parfois on
critique critiquer quelqu'un c'est pas
le mépriser ses tresses argentin devenir
aussi parfois critique un truc et où je
ne méprise pas la personne et voilà je
vais te mets pétition en a d'autres qui
veulent venir là sur le plateau
s'expliquer comme alex à la couture est
un tube avec nous je suis déjà très en
retard pour mon dîner donc bus à g et
non t'inquiète pas tu es bien avec lui
ouvrait ses campus et du feq a annoncé
du tamaris et travailler comme annoncé
la radio ckoi du feuilleton je suis sûr
il ya plein de gens qui se posent la
question
je veux faire un petit bisou tous les
deux bien sûr mais aussi mais en trois
secondes m'excuse en revanche parce que
je le connais bien et j'ai baissé avec
couperet de keen'v qui du coup lui aussi
m'a mis un petit exposé sa vie quoi
j'avais dit que les ailes il ya quelques
jours quelques semaines que les nrj
music awards il fallait ouvrir avec une
star internationale
et j'ai dit bêtement un jour et sinon
pourquoi pas aussi ouvrir un jour avec
keen'v ouais mais ça vous dirait avec
une québécoise prend dans la gueule
fouet il a mal pris il a bien fait parce
que je les aime beaucoup d alors
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il ya un truc c'est que mathieu je laime
aussi par cette saison qu'il vend et
c'est pour ça qu'il est excellent pour
l'émission il beaucoup mathieu tu sais
que c'est pour ça que je t'aime aussi
mais là un petit grâce du corps comme
pour les prochains heures
[Rires]